engine for a whole minute so shall we
start
yep let's get started so let me
let me first so welcome everybody to the
session today and we
have a fantastic cast of speakers i'm
really looking forward to that
um this will get couple of housekeeping
things
if you are an attendee and you want to
ask questions
uh raise your hand if you
are the finalists and you want to ask
questions
uh you couldn't mute yourselves you i
think
all the speakers are okay with this and
and or you could post things in the chat
um and uh what else
will go down after that
uh so let me without my
much more housekeeping you remind me if
i forgot something
introduce our first speaker today
and i'm really really really happy you
have
uh saharasboro gives the first talk
today
i've heard it before it is beautiful so
if speakers today hardly need
any introduction but um just to mention
one of the
main things separate borough was famous
for
um being one of the few people who
proved overbound
original lower bounds for monotone
circuits
um he
had done beautiful working bounded
arithmetic and
the proof complexity uh in
bounded arithmetic last last friday we
talked about
uh rsuv isomorphism for example
and um
he's also well known for uh
probably the most important barrier
result in circuit complexion often
bounded around making the
natural proof area and hopefully
you might hear a bit about it today
in addition to that uh done some
um quantum complexity communication
complexity some other complexity and
some
deep mathematics
like algebras stuff um he
unsurprisingly got numerous prices for
that uh just to mention the
global price for the barrier results for
natural proofs
and i think an even venus price for
circuit lower bounds
there is nothing much to say but uh i'd
rather
let you speak for himself so please the
floor of you
all right thank you very much tonya for
the nice introduction
again if you want to ask questions
please unmute yourself
and ask highly preferred method so
and uh first of all this talk today will
be highly speculative
and so here it is i apologize that it's
about
uh some somewhat old stuff uh i will
talk here at simon's
i mean virtual talk somewhere in my in
my
more modern things and
another uh apology i
already made is that some of your
or many of you have seen this dog before
a longer version of it but i still hope
i made a few changes great so we'll
start with our favorite program p
versus np i think at this point in the
game
everyone here knows what it is but
we are going to tweak this question a
bit
so the first version we may ask
and that's how it was or attract
people to write attack it's or it's are
in this form
it's a slightly stronger version and
it's asking whether languages in np have
uh polynomial size circuits let me
remind you that p slash poly is anything
or is non-uniform p which means
everything you can compute for its
polynomial size circuits
so then we can further relax discretion
and ask are there any explicit boolean
functions not in b slash polar which
explicit being in good old sense
in mathematical sense not necessarily
empire or something
which you would recognize as explicit
and so then we may ask this question
which looks ridiculous but
as we will see it is not at least for
the purposes of my talk today
and this question is
this our question is actually
even more relaxed version are there any
boolean functions
that cannot be computed by polynomial
size
circuits well of course
i have put here a question mark but uh
of course we all know
that it is the case it's classical
result by shannon
somewhat verified by lupanov
later and it says that
it is indeed the keys and we have
functions and
actually almost all functions are hard
so here is some notation c of fn is the
circuit size
of my function f in some standard basis
so almost all of them are exponential
almost
all functions are exponential and that's
basically the on
the whole parameter it's a simple
application of the pitch on whole
principle
but let's look closer at this probe so
what's really going on is that if you
want to run
this argument then you are wants to be
able to count really well
uh and by really well i mean you are
going to be
able to count really really large
numbers
so you want to count up to double
exponential
psi double er double exponent in
the number of variables because it's the
overall number of your boolean
functions or at least after this number
but still you have to count
really a lot and that's uh that
will be the main theme in my talk today
is that actual uh right the main
principle
is what you can do depends on how
well you can count right so maybe
you should use it in k-12 education in
uh
or classes on arithmetic but that's
really
that will be the divided incline
everything will depend on
what is the maximum number you can see
in your arguments
and you can count output that number
so let me now revisit this question
are there any boolean functions not in p
slash poly
and for the purposes of my talk first of
all
we are going to be interested in proof
theory
so we are going to study whether this
equation is probable
somewhere or not or
using some class of methods and
uh if i if there are any logicians here
or group theorists then we will
understand
for the purposes of this talk or we will
understand
for serious slightly more broadly it's
not necessarily a first order
series or prepositional is here it's
something that
some class of methods that you can
rigorously define
uh that's that word you don't compare
your minds on
it must be rigorously defined but other
than that it can be
described in by various means and
natural proofs that we will see is one
of the examples
so and let me now
put here my favorites one of my favorite
sentences
because sir well you do algorithms you
do
whatever you process and when you cannot
do something then you
start to explain others why you are so
stupid
answer as you see here this principle
was not invented by complexity theorists
but still that's basically what we are
going to do in this talk
as i said it's highly speculative so let
me
and uh yes i forgot to say
that uh we will be it will be one of
our guiding principles is that
we will be interested in our pro systems
again broadly understood for which even
that
statement is supposed to be heard
so are on there in those four systems in
which you can first
formulate this statement and
seconds uh this blue word anya
does not make your life any simpler
so proven that npe is not in p slash
product is supposed to be more or
at least as hard as following it for any
boolean functions
let me briefly state a few motivations
[Music]
so first of all because mathematicians
do it
we know great independence result in
mathematical logic
atom of choice continuum hypothesis or
the other's incompleteness crm
and it's self explaining that it is
interesting
the second uh motivation
uh it actually started in the book by
gary johnson 79
of 79 in there as many of you know
in the first chapters they carefully
laid
down this principle
that the theory of np completeness is
good for many reasons
but one of them is that you can explain
to your boss
why you cannot do the job so that's the
second reason
the third reason are it is of course uh
because uh since this problem so so far
mathematics never gave up on its
problems
it kept solving them if necessary for
centuries and as we know
eventually they get solved so we have to
continue
and so like in complexities here
computational complexity theory i mean
it is the same hope we are going to
focus
our research in the right direction
by just uh
saying what and why does not work so
it's uh the ideology that we used in our
paper
on natural pearls of course or are as
weird as
steven and mir had expected everyone
misused that sentence
and stood the paper air like ball blue
circuit lower bounds do something else
well we cannot do anything about it it
was not our
intention our intention was just that we
showed what does not work
and so let's take it from there
and this shirt but also import
force i'm sorry but also very important
motivation is occurs about by products
so again that's what complex this year
is about
you approve something totally useless
and then
something comes out of it that made the
difference in the real world
even if you did not even think about it
well
the same sort of happens
in this business as well
all right so what's next so our
diagonalization uh it was
the first it probably was the first
barrier
let me go over this slide very quickly
so it's a pro system in my sense right
so if you have a complexity result
then the problem system it simply says
that it should be thorough in all oracle
worlds
it's well defined it's not of course
like the use opero system
but still it is rigorously defined and
we all know this classical series by
baker gil and salary
is that this pro system is not capable
of doing or proving kids rp is equal to
np
or its complement that's probably the
first
uh manifestation uh that was probably
the first manifestation of this idea
that approach system is not necessarily
rules and axioms in first order logic
it might be something else but uh
something reasonable
so what does it mean to be reasonable
yeah again get me a try so
four will be a magic number for some
reasons
throughout my talk let me formulate for
constraints and visually
that i would like to have
in a in a framework that a
barrier or roof or whatever you like
to study this kind of things these kind
of things i mean
so the first of course is
that your system should not be able to
solve this creation in the obvious way
by
counting and it rules out front of
systems like
like tools well uh shy probably will
disagree with this
but we will listen to what he can say
are in an hour about a stronger
consistency
so what's uh for 40 purpose of my talk i
really don't want to be
i really don't want shannon arguments to
be formalizable
in my pro system there because it's a
it's not an interesting move
i want i want it to be out
so the seconds are which is
very important are very important is
that if you take your favorite result in
circuit complexity
and we do have a few results as you know
and so by the way it is an excellent
book one of the best books i've ever
seen
so if you take any result from this book
then
you really don't want to work hard
on uh proving it in your system
you don't sir you don't want to write
papers you don't want to introduce
something some new concepts you just
take it and it should be
doable in your system in a
straightforward way
so hands returning to my accounting
scheme turns out that now all
those results are well exactly occurs
from that book exactly of course for the
chapter
that talks about shannon accounting
arguments and lupanos improvements
are all other results they use only
counting up or
polynomial in the number of instances so
little n of course stays everywhere
for the number of variables so it is
just polynomial the number of your
instances
so all those are all those problems they
use counting only after
this number which is single exponential
right so this work is self explaining
we are really one proof system that
people care
and sages are probably the weakest
points
or the weakest point of natural words
because somehow that's what we cooked up
i will show you what we did
in several slides so
butts are still we have some motivations
but
other than that usually it should be
natural the pro system should be
somehow of interest i cannot quantify it
and of course the first
thing is that we really want to hope to
make
progress so and in logic
you make progress if uh
usually meta mathematics of your problem
system
so what you can extract from rows
basically it's a
somehow matches mathematics so the other
thing is theorem
it is uh meta mathematics is uh
formulas or that you prove you import
them and
then uh it is the same semantics
about integers your whole system is
arguing about
and if it looks uh very if it looks
abstract
uh so you'll then let me point out this
recent
breaks or result by albert and
mueller alberta and
they proved something extremely concrete
improved complexity not all the
extremely concrete or
automatizability of resolution but if
but what has been open for decades and
they really use this self-referring
argument
so it's not if you are interested in
concrete things then you are still
you still want to hear it right here shy
again probably disagrees with this
we are going to listen sweetly
all right so let me remind you what are
natural rules and i will be very quick
uh because uh this book is
is about something relevant but still
something else
so uh these are two pieces of common
wisdom
so the first one is that if you want to
prove laura bounce rebellion functions
and you should look at how it looks like
study its properties and then move it to
lower bounds
and the second piece of wisdom it says
that if you want to analyze your
problems then you should carefully look
into them
uh do a proof system and blah blah blah
so uh the starting point of natural
process is that we dismiss both
both of them so namely
instead of even trying to understand
what our group looks like
so we are going to think about it
sometimes creatively
it's uh sometimes it's not
straightforward and
then we are going to conclude that
the same argument can be applied not
only to your function of
interest but through aggregates or deal
of
other functions so which
are which are gives rise to
the set of boolean functions pm to which
your argument can be applied in a sense
and so that's the only thing we need in
our
we need in our model so we only
look at this set pm and then we
formulize
formalize so for http and
so in
right sorry pm and cn on this slide
are the same so and then we simply
write the properties of this
set of functions first of all of course
we wanted to make sense and the second
two properties
they are debatable but still that's
uh what happens in our all
or almost all known proofs and
you really want to understand what you
are doing
so which means that our set pn
must be computable or in polynomial time
in this quantity
and it must have large
density so once you have a good method
then you really are going to be able to
apply it to
sufficiently many functions usually it
is even
better than that usually it is just
almost all functions but so to be on the
safe side
so let us share against
our four items from the wish list
uh there is no obvious counting solution
you cannot count that's why we have here
constructiveness right so if you count
up for
larger than that number then it will not
be
in polynomial time
so that is what we call
naturalization so
there are some technicalities which are
monotone formulas
or basically because it is not
so easy to define
goods or distribution over
the good distribution over monetary
formulas but more you can do it
so as i said this is this is the weak
point of natural groups
so you can prove but here is at least
one justification for it which is also
alone
that's uh it's written here
if you approach a penis card and your
pro system is
closed over explore then you somehow
and you understand what you are going
then you should be able to tell which
one of these stories hurt and it gives
you largeness because
you have then half of all functions
and here
on the fourth era item about mathematics
versus meta mathematics
it looks so it is almost here because
our one of our axioms it has polynomial
inside of it and we study
writes short circuits small circuits but
so the cage here of course is uh
is it really a problem that now we have
changed our
measure that it's not small and that it
is 2 to it really a problem well uh
turns out it is the main and actually
the only problem about natural works is
that
you really can prove things even in this
form
so that's the main theorem of natural
proof so modular
standards are cryptographic assumptions
there is no natural profit against
general circuits self-defeating
arguments in its price
good so uh as i said uh
there is lots of work on natural proofs
and
so people disagree with many of these
points
some people agree some people both agree
and disagree at the same time
and let me stop it here
so and this is uh this is one very
important by-product
so it is sir it will be
the same throughout my whole talk that
we
actually are interested in our
inputs we are measuring our main
size measure is this capital n it will
always be the same
which is uh the number of instances in
my problem which means that your
boolean functions are given as true
stable
and one by-product is
that this work
with sooner rich it highlighted the
importance of this problem
which these days is called minimum
circuit size problem
it is here it is obvious it is the set
of
all false tables or the corresponds to
simple functions and let me just
say that there has been a lot of
very interesting and wonderful and
important research on this program and
so
somehow our paper helped to understand
its importance and that it is a really
good thing to study so
in complexity terms if we forget about
all
our motivations then in complexity terms
natural which occurs can be easily
formulated in terms of
this this problem has
as is written here
right so that's it with natural powers
let's move on and
so these are the two points i repeat
here at the two points
that's natural approach this means today
in the in the remaining of my time today
we are going
uh so now so still dismiss the first
point
as i said we are interested in approve
systems that
actually do not distinguish between
explicit functions and any functions
but we want to replace the second
uh second point with its opposite
so we really want our good persistence
in uh in the good old sense of formal
series and of course as antonin already
said
there is lots of work about it so here i
really wants to say just for
just a bit so bowen tutorials magic is
just piano
arithmetic where you focus on bounded
quantifiers
bounded by terms so you also have
sharply bounded quantifiers
and it is important that it is just a
normal
first order here
small no edges axioms
inference rules so uh again
as almost all of you or all of you know
are as one is the most important
syria in the whole family there is a
higher record there is a fairly
hierarchical it closely models her
complexity hierarchy but i don't have
much time today so
i will talk only about this to one and
the fourth item in my wish list it
is answered by this fundamental theorem
by symbols
but it's it's uh from his book about
boundaries metrics that basically
started
this whole subject is that if you prove
something existential in this theorem
and a
is a simple simple indicator now uh
you have a well you know then it can be
witnessed by polynomial time
function so here we see here a
polynomial time
that corresponds to meta mathematics of
our approach system
and so it's the same concept we are
going to study
uh therefore it's good news for us
so sorry it should be as one has to one
reversed
so now the game
it's a it's a shorter version of the
talk i have to skip many details
that i gave before and uh
but you can finalize the question we are
interested
in so here our reports are sub
exponential function to avoid circuitry
realities
and this is the equation
whether we can prove the existence of a
boolean function friend
so
uh right
uh there is no obvious counting solution
because we don't know
the answer to this question we don't
know whether whether
it is probable or not therefore there
are no
mounting solutions obvious counting
solutions
this is the second part is also very
easy
and very natural so if you look at the
same statements but for
for restricted circuit models then
you can really do it in this system
it is extremely straightforward so
i did it once and mostly i focused on
the creation
or are there weaker systems than this
where you can prove all that stuff
from our status book and
yeah and so it is very natural
very simple so uh
of course bogutorius making that what we
love
for many good reasons it's not only
because
we are able to do this stuff and
now comes now comes an interesting part
so that i will show on the next slide
and
it's good that i was able to get to that
slide
so but one clarification is
that we cannot hold to get to
all the way up to this bonnet arithmetic
unconditionally
so i like in natural process i do allow
you
arbitrary reasonable complexity
cryptographic assumptions that are short
of
our np is not equal to coin p because
that makes the whole game trivial
so again it's a short version let me
just mention a competing framework
which was
which is promoted by uh yankovic
so in this framework you allow even
more restricted counting you cannot
really call
count up to capital m but
uh on the other hand it's no longer
simple existential formulas you allow
lots of quantifiers it's very
interesting framework or
connected in many respects to what i am
talking about here but i don't have time
to
uh talk about it
so in now again it's it will be s21
so and now we can reformulate or
the equations we are interested in in
terms of
prepositional proof complexity because
again there is a cage here
due to sharply bonded quantifiers but
more symbols
theorem almost implies that or if you
prove
this in s21 then should be there should
be some explicit sequence
of functions for which you can prove the
same thing
and once you have a quantifier free
statements or only sharply about the
quantifier then
or 25s then you can translate it
so prepositional
proof complexity propositional logic you
can express it as
a prepositional formula
the fact that the function f n is part
and
the size of this formula again we
use our convention or our main principle
that we don't care how we encode it
it's simply given by its truth table we
have enough
uh memory or enough time to
just import it as it was table and
measure everything
as a polynomial in terms of the length
of this
and now comes the main slide
so we have now we have this
square namely
we have four symbolic arithmetic
and uh it shares very popular
topic connections bounded arithmetic and
uniform complexity classes
are given by various witnessing syrians
symbols here involves the first syrian
from this family if you if you if you
have something in boundaries
involved it's arithmetic as to one then
you get
something binomial time computable so
if if you have sigma if you have delta
zero will be a quantifier free
formulas then you can
translate them through propositional pro
systems
and this will give your you will just
work in now in more much more convenient
and more elegant prepositional
uh world for example s21
again s21 is different s21
gets translated so extend it for again
so this is also this connection is
very uh
is standard in computational complexity
so every
uniform complexity class essentially
every uniform complexity class you have
associated non-uniform class
so what we really need is the fourth
arrow
right so you would really expect a force
arrow on this picture i give you a
prepositional proof
it argues about computational concepts
and you want to
extract some computation something
computational out of it
and then apply your knowledge like we
did in natural proofs or
in our in this implication apply our
knowledge to get conditional results
and it's embarrassing that we almost
cannot do it
and i don't understand why
right so let me
give you a few definitions for aggregate
systems
resolution extended fractal
system well i believe that uh everyone
knows
what it is so i have only yes at the
minutes left i don't want to spend time
here
all right so the success story and it is
precisely a modal case of
what we would like to have idea
is called feasible interpolation that's
precisely what we
what we would love to have so i give
your
special special apology and it all
it all is applied here and
then you ask and
then you extract from it something
computational which is called physical
interpolation
so you can apply it to several systems
of interest
but then turns out
that you cannot go very far along these
lines
uh simply feasible interpolation
are fails for more
uh for
for stronger systems for systems that we
are really interested in
well i mean we are interested in all
those systems
as well as everyone at this workshop
already knows by
this time but for different reasons
so here is a byproduct of this
one by product of this it is simply
because it is simply one
quite amazing thing about rock
complexity is that
really it is the same phenomenon
unlike circuit complexity we really
don't know if there
are any hard tautologies for regular or
extended regular systems
there is no accounting argument here so
in this paper
uh they tried to come up with some error
with
some examples but uh i guess uh they
indicated themselves that it was not
very conclusive and
most of those results were are
solved i mean short proofs infrared or
exchange rate were found later on
the principle is that these systems are
really hard
so we really want some arguments that we
don't understand
ourselves and at the moment i have
owned it so and i think everyone has
only so
reasonably convincing examples of what
might be hard
for fedor excellent fragrance the first
is random cnns
it's just because you're here you don't
understand why
or if you pick a random sienna why is it
unsatisfiable you'll have to count for
for that and so it's beyond the reach of
our system and it is
the second example is coming from this
business or proving that
npa is not equal or is not in p slash
partner
uh it is uh the second
candidate cards topology and it is
uh the game which is uh we don't
understand it's
to the extent that we don't even know if
it is true or not
which makes it perfect
so i have only a few minutes left
so let me very briefly say that we have
some ad hoc results for
so that's now what we are going to study
we are going to
try to understand why this thing is
difficult for various
verification systems we have a few
unconditional results
and it also does not go quite far
so and so that's basically the last
thing i want so
sure and uh do you have five minutes
first forever why not please
yes okay good so i got right to finish
in five minutes
so and so that's one suggestion
that uh is still uh
which which made it anywhere so
uh improve all this all the stuff to
stronger power systems
so let me start with reminding you about
natural growth
and the way you provide it is that you
construct
pseudorandom function generator if you
have an ordinary
one-way function then you get an
ordinary
to random bit generator out of it and
you can either construct it's using
general construction by mikali
goldwasser and rakov
or you can take for example missile dig
drastic that immediately gives you a
conjectural
function generator and so this is
basically the whole proof
you have to supply a few details
so the idea is to try to understand
what it looks or what it might look like
in the prepositional world so again i
have a mapping
i have a pro systemp so
our idea was that if i give you nissan
vectors on generator
or any other generator
another reasonable generator and i i
give you identically zero string
right and i ask you is it is it true or
not that this string is not
in the image of your generator it's not
generated by any seed
then it's really impossible to do
so if your generator is reasonable then
you cannot answer
this basic equation you cannot really
pinpoint any
particular strain in the image of the
generator that is
or not
in the domain of your generator that is
not in the image
and that's what we take as a definition
of our hardness
so the idea is of course that we can use
so if i give you any string b then your
system does not prove that big is not in
the image of this
so answer the proposal is simply
well the proposal is simply to try to
somehow uh right general generators is
something that is well studied income
interpretation complexity
and the proposal is of course to
search for this missing force error or
using maybe at least as in as
their inspirations uh
what is law in the computational world
so in a sense good news is that it's uh
it extends
feasible interpolation so if you have
physical interpretation for your system
then you basically can
do it with a slight twist
of your generator
and this is the main conjecture
is that if you take
any nissan literature generator just for
simplicity and for concreteness and you
base it on any function
then or it becomes hard for extreme
regular system
so that was made almost 20 years ago
there has been some work
but not much on it and it is still wide
open and
basically i would like pre that was
the main purpose one of the main
purposes of my talk is to draw attention
to this project so here is
what we know we don't know very much
so we know this conjecture for width
resolution rates
for polynomial calculus
for even even for resolution it is
frustrating
because we don't know it for
exponentially
many output bits only only n squared
and it is a very important word by young
rajcik
so which is again the same principle you
can iterate
these generators as you do in a
circuit complexity and for example for
resolution you can get slightly better
you can get to cube
and so that's probably the best you can
do
at the moment it is the proof system
where you can
lift this stuff so our jedi random
generator for the system well i hope you
know what it is it is a strong
consistency for which
will be in all these statements so
and as i mentioned several times there
are many other suggestions
so often obvious open problem so
it it should stay as to one it is uh
just the same yr
as ue isomorphism tonya mentioned before
so it is the main conjecture again uh it
is connected to models here
somehow so now
we have had several breaks or results in
cutting planes in
several last years but as far as i know
they form a don't imply unconditional
hardness
of this statement it would be a great
program accessible problems
or accessible problem i mean well unless
i missed something and there is a simple
reduction
which i don't see so perfectly is there
its hardness for cutting planes or
sum of squares as far as i know it is
open
unconditionally conditional you can
apply physical interpolation
and so the same equation for bounded
depths fragment
we missed some techniques basically
randomly early administrations were
not suited very very well for the task
but
these people they explained to us that
it is much more
versatile method than we had thought
about it
so again even for resolution we have
also apply other methods we don't have
pseudo-random generator for resolution
that that is really in the range we are
interested in and it's very loose
because
yeah it's variables creation right
thank you so much this is fantastic this
is such an inspiring talk
to everybody questions comments
please i have a question
so you you motivated the the cells for
natural proof by
you didn't want to have counting up to
doubly exponential
but that can be then you could have said
that the proof should be of exponential
length so
the proof should be in p space
why not take a simpler definition of
natural
uh no uh it's uh
so no each user it is not uh
what we want to achieve it's uh i view
it as a chest for
what what we are doing is all right
it's sanity check it only at the same
teacher
it's not like i really it's it's not my
purpose
but simply if your system be it natural
process or anything else if it does not
pass just check then it means that
it's the game or it's not
what you're interested in it's not the
problem
it's not the purpose but sir it's
excellent
okay thanks
more questions like if i can ask a
question
you ended with a comment about lifting
versus
natural proofs so i was wondering if you
think there's any connection between the
two
and the techniques or the approaches
i think it's more again i had
to revise which means
vandalize my large stock
fitted here right
so in the long version it refers
only to this result
okay so our natural proofs or
so it's our it comes it comes here in
this business
or if you uh have a system with physical
interpolation
right and you want absurd random natural
pseudorandom generator
then you'll go very primitive lifting
extremely primitive
but still you're doing it
these are either is there anything like
that for natural pros or parameter
systems
our it's very limited equation
such as in this diagram that you have on
the slides
so you were asking about the arrow on
the bottom
so your proposal is to to use these
crosstalk formulas the
most tau formulas
this formula is saying that something is
not in the image of
a pseudorandom generator
this should be the arrow down it's sir
it's one possibility
so and so it's it's main is it your
conjecture
or is it that this is the right arrow or
you suggest it is one
possibility or well this conjecture
is made or in my annual paper
it's so it's quite official
uh or are you asking her in the reverse
direction
so if you're asking whether this
you propose this as the solution of what
the arrow should be so i know that you
propose this conjecture but
do you propose this as
the only solution of this arrow or
well well this solution cares
extremely well
maybe a bit dirty but extremely powerful
something extremely powerful behind it
might be a bad
it might be totally incorrect but you
don't have any signals
[Music]
at least i am not aware of anything that
i would recognize
as a project as a plan so to get it
right right
i have tried lots of things and
but it's very frustrating you have an
object right which is
essentially a sequence of circuits
where there are no psi circuits everyone
computes
each one of these circuits computes one
because it's a tautology and he wants to
get some computational
content out of it and you fail
i don't i don't understand why even in
30 years i guess i
still don't understand why different
so each essay which is simply it's a
it's a it's like
democracy i would compare this or
gender generators with democracy it may
be a bad system it might be a lousy
system but it's better
than anything else
[Music]
um i i have a quick question so you were
talking about
s12 as kind of the right system the
right power to
talk about complexity but in recent
years people have been working with
systems that formalized probabilistic
reasoning
apc1 and friends what do you think about
about that um
it is first of all it is
definitely very interesting line of
research and
i certainly don't want to say anything
negative about it but
somehow i feel that
you mean this one okay
somehow i
feel quite strongly in terms of
this thing it's uh it's uh it
looks like this systems
they in many cases
they were somehow uh
so formalize or capture particular
things it's not the case with valid
arithmetic right
arithmetic was not invented so or
something
perhaps it was related to capture
polynomial time
it's not with piano it's not the case
with piano
it was entered to capture all fighting
arguments somehow
these systems i'm not sure that
thank you thank you so much so
more questions comments can you um
go back to the slide where you have this
generator that you talk about
uh what's from sorry the nissan victor
generator uh the first time that you
talked about it
well no it's not brackets it's forward
yes yeah yeah this one
so can you go back one slide
uh the one where you have the mapping
from
uh functions yeah this one what exactly
what exactly are you saying here so i'm
just trying to understand this well i'm
saying
i'm saying that if you take
any a reasonable generator for example
nissan vinderson right
and i ask your equation like i give you
identically 0 or
almost all strings here are not in the
image of this generator
yes yeah if i if i if i am asking
whether identically zero string is in
the image of this generator or not you
will not be able to answer this question
regardless of any proof complexity
just fix it or in any reasonable way of
course you can always manually
you can manually ensure that it is not
there but if you don't
play any tricks then you will not be
answered you will
be able to answer this question about
identically zero string
okay thanks
and we simply mineralize it for all
other strains
great well thank you so much this is
fantastic
thank you tonya and i'm now giving
four let me see how do i
stop sugar
thank you ah
this is great so pavel would you like to
share
yota and unmute yourself
yes
[Music]
yeah so do you want to make a short
break before i start
uh um do people want to break
now do people want to break in
any i think a five-minute break uh might
be good because we have been at this one
hour now
so maybe okay yeah uh let's take maybe
uh three four minutes break
and uh actually people can use this uh
to
ask more you like
and we'll start in four minutes okay
i just try sharing my screen yeah
please
so how does it look like
it's not full screen but it's visible
okay let me do it
[Music]
presentation
[Music]
oh yeah that sounds great you should be
okay
you can see the slides can see your
mouse that's great
how do i exit
[Music]
yeah okay stretch my legs
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
alexander yep may i ask
an intermediate break question
absolutely
yes that was very very amazing talk
to me um i i'm wondering
two questions first do you think
what is your personal belief does a
proof system propositional proof system
exist
that is strictly stronger than extended
trigger
and second what might it look like then
i don't have it i think it's uh it's
actually a viral i think it's a question
for you right
uh well of course uh sasha knows very
well these things but no
no no no what's what about our extended
foreign
yeah so so we already studied a long
time ago and uh
also in my talk is
our quantified propositional
calculi or calculate
so where
you have the usual
second calculus formalization but you
use quantified
prepositions and they seem to be
stronger so this is
just one next step after frigate
or extended fragrance but
there are other things like like um
creatures implicit proofs
you can take basically any improved
system
and make the so-called implicit proof
system from it and this is a kind of
jump that
we cannot prove that it's strictly
stronger but
potentially it could be a kind of jump
like in endocardia theory that
produces a stronger system from one
proof system
and there are other things like the
first order theories
spruce systems for uh prepositional
calculus and then you get the extremely
strong improved systems
so um yes whoever where to read about it
so in
in leon's book of course
thank you but
of course that there are uh different
opinions so young clay check things that
it's quite possible that
these proof systems are not stronger
than they are
oh theoretically you can believe that np
is equal to coin p
right yes which which immediately closes
all these creations
[Music]
so should i uh so shall we start
yeah if you don't mind putting on the
[Music]
sides
and meantime
so um speakers today need no
introduction
but let me still introduce final good
luck
and uh if you did anything with proof
complexity you
always start circuit you've seen pavel's
name
over and over and over again and uh from
um from lower bounds from feasibility
violation i think your name is the most
overbound
complexity that i can think of uh
cutting planes
uh the similar result is lower bounds
for chitin planes
um from the point of view of mathematics
uh pavel has a great book called
mathematics of first order arithmetic
and a more recent book
which is a gentle introduction
the logical foundation of mathematics
and complexity
it's gentle but it still talks about a
lot of
really advanced concept
that uh sasha mentioned uh also
if you do algorithm for sat
uh probably the most well known uh
algorithm for start
um exponential algorithm is ppaz
and again uh this is foggles work
so many things that i can't even mention
all of them circuit complexity
other connections so addresses that i
will talk about
this and the beautiful connection
between different areas of complexity
and stuff
please thank you antonina for
a very flattering introduction
so my talk will be hopefully short
and definitely very elementary
i will not talk about new stuff i will
actually talk about it
i have already spoken a couple of times
but each time i still find
some details that
i can present in a better way or
complement things in it
so
let's start with some background from
the foundations of
mathematics we use various theories to
formalize arithmetic or set
theory these theories
are of increasing strength
here on the slide we have t2 which is
bounded arithmetic so i should have also
included s12 that was mentioned before
which is a
fragment of t2 then we have
a fragment of piano arithmetic called i
sigma 1 which is induction for sigma 1
formulas
a stronger theory than that is that the
arithmetic is
the so-called second order arithmetic
which is not
arithmetic formalized in in this in
the second order
proof calculus because there is no any
but it's uh
it's a an extension of arithmetic by
the sets subsets of
interpret interpreted as subsets of
three integers
non-negative integers then a thermal
franco theory
and we can go on by adding new axioms uh
such a strongly inaccessible cardinal or
the existence of measurable cardinals
and obtained stronger and stronger
theories
and these theories are stronger we can
prove that they are stronger because
um of uh ghetto theorem
and they in fact prove more uh true pi
one sentences
assuming that these theories are are
true that they describe the true
true sentences of arithmetic
but the question that is
interesting for us is whether they prove
more sentences relevant to
computational complexity this is what
you would like to know
so this is one thing that we can ask and
another thing is if you take some
theories that
differ in in a way
like uh p differs from
np and np differs from uh
sigma two p and so on
then we can ask whether this theorists
form an increasing hierarchy and this is
uh open and probably very difficult
problem because here we cannot apply
uh god of theorem of course
we cannot prove that we cannot apply the
theorem but uh
we know we know one thing that the
consistency of this theories is so
strong that
none of these theories prove the
consistency of the the weakest one so we
cannot use
the consistency to separate these
theories
here's an example of what i
am very much interested in uh given a
problem and an algorithm that solves p
what is the weakest theory that proves
the soundness
of a by the soundness of a i mean that
the algorithm solves the problem
or given a problem in a time bounty you
can ask
what is the biggest theory circuit for
some algorithm prove that
a source p in time t
here is an example that uh appeared in
in our paper long time ago
if factoring is hard then
uh the theory denoted by s12 which sasha
mentioned
briefly does not prove the sadness of
any polynomial time algorithm for
primality
so we are in the situation that we do
know that there is a polynomial time
algorithm for primality
but assuming a reasonable conjecture the
s12
doesn't prove the service of this
algorithm so it's conceivable that uh
[Music]
that there are algorithms that are so
complex or tricky or
like use deep mathematics
that they they are not provable in
weak systems of arithmetic
or set theory so for instance here we
are not
able to prove the soundness of aks
algorithm
in any fragment of t2 but
at the same time we we don't have a
reason to
believe that it is not provable in in
t2 except that we don't know how to do
it but
there may be ways to argue that
it's not possible by placing
these things into a hierarchy of
total function and p problems but uh i
am
a bit digressing so
uh here is what i mean by cellular so of
an algorithm
[Music]
so we have to be careful how we
formalize these questions
we can always formalize an algorithm so
that
zfc or any an fx theory does not prove
the soundness we can just
embed the consistency statements of this
theory
into the algorithm and then we are not
able to prove that it is sound
but we can ask the the opposite question
or something formally opposite
is it possible to formalize every
algorithm that
its soundness is provable in parent
arithmetic
or some other fixed theory
now this question is
vague and unfortunately
i'm not able to formalize it in a way so
that
it doesn't have a trivial answer but
this is what i would be very much
interested
so instead i will show today some
related things that are not exactly this
question
but of the same nature
what i i'm going to present
is something that can be uh
presented as syntactic
classes versus semantic classes
syntactic classes
do have complete problems while semantic
classes
usually do not
and we usually
are not able to prove that there is no
complete problem
but we can argue that there are some
good reasons to believe that there are
no complete problems
and what i'm going to talk about is
three conjectures or several conjectures
that are of the form that
saying that there are no complete
problems in certain
classes uh
russell impala doesn't like the word
conjecture
because he suggests to call things
hypothesis but
in this case it's something that i uh
very much believe that they are true
that we should
eventually be able to prove it like we
believe that
p is not equal to so we don't say that
what is the semantic can you define some
anti-class
okay
so semantic class
is a class that is defined in such a way
that
we have to prove the defining condition
that
the problem belongs to the class so for
instance
p is a syntactic class because we can
present every polynomial algorithm
in such a way that we know from the code
that you write down
that it runs in polynomial time
this is not
the definition is not the syntactic but
if we if you put into the code of the
of the algorithm a clock that
that will stop the algorithm
after polynomial number of steps then we
know for sure and
that it will stop after perennial time
and uh
the dog makes noise here i will have to
do something
but other classes
typically randomized classes are not of
this form you write down
an algorithm and you uh
accept this as a definition of the
of uh set in this class if you prove
that it accepts the
input with certain probability or not
sorry i have to make a shortcut
to see what's going on
the dog doesn't have a mute button no
okay so he's now quiet okay so let's go
on
no my question is when we use the monty
class we're actually very loose about it
because i can always ask when you say
all the all the algorithms in some
running some time are saying what
theoretic universe are you talking about
so my claim is that when we use the
monthly classes we are really very loose
and if we try to be precise we will have
to
be better defined into saying what class
of models are we talking about
well i i don't understand this so i i
think that the
semantic class is defined precisely a
lot like rpp
for the they may be equal to p and then
they are not uh
semantic anymore because they can be
defined synthetically but uh
otherwise they are
semantic so um
excuse me
so
um
he's sorry so so this this dog is very
clever he can open the doors
so it's difficult to contain him
somewhere
so anyway
this is not another precise definition
but
but we will see examples and maybe
it will be better to look at the
examples that i will
present is it okay
[Music]
yes sasha just gave a good a good answer
i'm happy with his answer
okay
yes maybe so
you have to say uh in the chat
if there is no recursive enumeration of
machines computing languages from this
class
i say it again uh semantic there is no
recursive enumeration
of machines computing languages from
this class
yes yes the the reason why why we do
have
complete problems in syntactic classes
is because we can enumerate
the the algorithms of course
it may not work always because the
enumeration may be not so so
effective but but this is just
a rule of thumb it's not not a precise
statement
so let's get to the examples so the
first
uh item on
my list or in the title is the
set of pathologies so let's uh
restrict to dnf technologies but this is
not important
just to be more concrete
we have proof systems and a proof system
is something that is complete that
there is a proof for every pathology
and sound that it doesn't prove for
non-pathologies the completeness is easy
to
ensure by uh
embedding some um uh well-known proof
system
in into it and then uh say if we believe
that the
resolution is complete then we can add
to each proof system resolution and then
we know that it is complete
uh based on the assumption that
resolution is complete
and we don't have to prove essentially
anything
but the soundness is a problem so if you
have a
very strong proof system then
you have to prove that it is sound it's
not it may be
a non-trivial thing
so this is uh how they are defined and
then we have uh
polynomial simulations i'll not define
them because we
we know this very well that you can if
you have one proof system
and the other proof system simulates
this proof system means that you can
assimilate the proofs of one system in
the other
so there is polynomial time function
that translate
translates proof system from one into
the other
and the conjecture is that
this condition of soundness
is indeed indeed syntactic that we
cannot uh
uh prove it easily
which means that uh there is now
consistent here that proves the
soundness of
all proof systems
so this this may be one possible
statement of this conjecture
and which is not
maybe completely obvious but easy that
this is equivalent to the condition that
there is no
proof system that simulates all other
proof systems
i will call this optimal proof systems
an optimal proof system is that
simulates all proof systems and also i
am omitting
the specification polynomial so
similarize mean
polynomialism was affected with that
computable functions i will not talk
about the length of
your red syntactic should be semantic
right
what did you say syntactic yes
this this should be semantic thank you
thank you
yes
i have a kind of selective brightness i
cannot
proof read my slides
in this light your slides are semantic
not syntactic
so uh okay and this conjecture is uh
is a fairly strange strong conjecture
because
in particular it implies that
exponential time is not
equal to non-deterministic exponential
time
and this is probably stronger than
p is not equal to mp
there is a related class which is the
class of
disjoint and p sets so this class
consists of
pairs of sets a b which are
and p and that they are disjoint
again we can define polynomial
reductions between
uh two elements of this class
this is quite natural we can use either
turing reductions or many one
which means that if you have two pairs
then the first set should be met into
the
first set of the other and the second
should be met
into the to the other so this is
something
that you can easily imagine
[Music]
and now the condition that these two
sets are
uh disjoint is a semantic
conscientious
i have to be careful not to confuse the
two things
semantic because if you write down the
definitions of
these sets you don't know whether
they are decision unless you write down
some
trivial think like like all the sets in
a start with with zero all the sets in b
start with
bit one so these are easily recognizable
but
it's easily recognizable that they are
destroying but in general it may be
hard to prove that they are disjoint
so we can state the conjecture that
there is no complete disjoint anti-pair
and this conjecture again is equivalent
to
this statement that there is no
consistent theory that proves that the
sharpness of all the discharged empty
pairs
now i'm stating this
conjecture at least the the second part
is stated
a bit not quite precisely
because what does it mean that the
theory doesn't prove
that there is not disjoint
this whether the theory proved that the
peristation
definitely depends on how you formalize
these pairs so you need to write down a
formula if you want to
talk about its probability
so to state this precisely i would need
to say that
it does not prove that this jointness of
all np pairs uh however you
formalize the pair so you take the the
best formalization
for which it should be the the easiest
way to prove that they are destroyed and
for for this you are still not
able to prove it in some theory
i mean you before
you're still not able to prove it in the
theory
all right so uh how
how these conjectures are connected
to show that they are connected
one can use the very
important concept of
canonical pairs of proof systems if
we have a proof system p
then um the canonical pair of the proof
system
is defined by sasha is
consists of a set of basically
you can view it as formulas that are
that have short proofs but to be
more precise what we use so we are using
uh
padding that uh limits the
the length of proof so it's a pair of
formula and
a number represented in a unarray
such that fee doesn't have
feed v has a refutation of length
at most n and the second set is
basically sad but uh we need
something that looks uh similar to ap
so we also use padding but it is just
depending that does nothing
so this uh pair uh somehow captures the
the strength of the proof system
uh because if p simulates q then
the pair corresponding to q is
polynomial reducible to
pair corresponding to p
this is this is very easy to prove
and the corollary of this is that
the conjecture about division np pairs
implies the conjecture about
proof systems for prepositional
tautologies
now let's let's get to
[Music]
total function np
so tfnp means total function and p
[Music]
which i define in the following way
[Music]
a problem in total function and p is
given by a binary
relation that is computable in
polynomial time
and a polynomial bound
such that the relation
defines a multivalued but total function
that is for for every a there is b
which is at most polynomially
longer than a such that it satisfies
the relation so this polynomial bound is
given just to be quite precise
but typically the polynomial bound is
already
implicit in the relation r so i will
often omit this parliament bound and
talk only about the operation
the problem associated with this
relation which has this property is to
find
for a given a to find b such that
it satisfies duration
so now again this
this condition is
uh semantical
you if you have a definition if you have
a formula for
r or a polynomial time algorithm
computing this binary relation
you you never know for sure that
this defines
a total function so you have to prove in
some theory
now again we we have reductions between
these problems
now i will just use r and r prime
for for these problems and then these
relations
this reduction are defined in the
obvious way
there are many one relations or during
relations
and it makes no difference for for the
conjecture
it can go into state so
this many one reduction is given by
two polynomial time computable functions
f
and g right so you want to compute
a witness for a in
a relation r uh and you can do in in
such a way that you first compute
f a and find the witness for f prime
and from this witness b and a
you you get the witness for a in in
relation r
but it may be more complicated to just
using
oracle for for the solution of r prime
anyway so so we have a
class and we have reductions and then we
can ask
whether there is a complete problem
but uh let's uh
just take an example so that we we are
sure that this
concept is not empty that uh
there are probably uh total function np
that are not solvable in polynomial time
because if everything is solvable in
polynomial time then
everything will be reduced reducible to
everything so
there will be a complete problem so
factoring
is an easy example
of a problem that is not soluble in
polynomial time but it's based on the
assumption that
it is hard so so the hardness of
factoring simply means that
this total function dp problem is not
released
to be computed by polynomial time so we
have at least
two different uh types of
total function np problems those that
are solvable important
time and those that that are
not
the conjecture about total function and
p is are much
stronger than that
than just saying that there are problems
that are not soluble in polynomial time
the conjecture is that there is no
complete other functional
problem so this is far more
[Music]
stronger than saying that there is
one problem that is not solvable
and again this can be stated
equivalently
in in logic that there is no consistent
theory that
proves totality of all total
function and p problems
uh these are of course
hopeless conjectures because they they
imply
p and q and p uh so do we have
any reasons to believe that that they
are true
one reason why i believe is this
is true is that it's very much like uh
the
like computable functions in
probably total computable functions in
theories
if you have increasing theories with
increasing strength
then you can show that also
the class of probably total computable
functions
increases in the structural series it
does not have to
increase always increase but at least in
the examples that i
showed at the beginning that this is
the case so the the only difference here
is that
in total function and p everything is
polynomial
well here it is computable so this
formal similarity is one reason
to believe that it may be
true the other reason
is that we already have
characterizations of
probably total functions
probably total
np functions in fragments of bounded
arithmetic
and these characterizations are of
increasing complexity
we cannot show that they are
of increasing complexity indeed but
at least formally the recent complexity
unfortunately we are still not able to
prove that
at least in relativized world they are
of increasing complexity
so this is one of the big open problems
in
in proof complexity to show that
this hierarchy of total function and the
problems is
increasing this is something that is
not hopeless i believe that it only
requires
proving some very complicated switch
implements
but so far nobody was able to do this
like with
uh a set of technologies we also have
a similar connection which uh destroyed
co-np pairs of vision
coin pieces
again polynomial reductions and curing
on many one are defined in the same way
and we can state the conjecture that
there is no complication currently there
again it's uh it's a syntactic class so
uh this is equivalent to
if true that then there is no
fixed year that produces predictions of
all coin b
bars
and we have a similar connection
as before namely that the conjecture
about
addition grantee pairs implies
the conjectures about total function
and p problems
so the situation so far is
[Music]
that
uh we have two branches of conjectures
one is uh about pathologies ambition and
p pairs and
another is about total function and p
and
vision can be pairs
but sat is still missing and
you cannot guess where sat is
it's not not obvious so we will look at
what that said so i want to spend a
little bit more time with sad because
this is a program in
simus simons which is focus on sat
so sat is of course very much different
from
thought but we also can
consider proof system for first set and
a proof system
what is a proof system for that it's uh
just any evidence that proves that
formula is satisfiable
what are polynomial simulations there
are exactly same as
photos that you transform proof in one
proof system
into another into a proof in
another proof system in polynomial time
but the difference is that
there is a the standard proof system
one very special proof system and this
is
just satisfying assignments if you want
to show that
a formula is satisfiable then the best
you can do is to provide a satisfying
assignment
and this this proof system is polynomial
bounded
while we believe that there is no
polynomial bounded proofs for uh
tautologies we we have a trivially
polynomially bounded proof system for
sub
oh sorry i thought i
i'm sorry we've been quite relaxed but
just realized
sorry okay i i don't have many slides
and i
skip something so i will finish five
minutes or
disappear hold on sorry for that
i just looked at the talk oh
yes so um
[Music]
okay so we so the situation
is different
but still there may be proof systems
that are not
polynomial bounded
now um an example of a proof system
first that is probably not
polynomially assimilable by by the
standard proof system
is the following one you you take the
standard proof system
and you add the basically
uh factoring into it which means that
you
take uh as a proof uh
any satisfying assignment or if the
the formula expresses that n is not a
prime
then n will be just the proof of this
and it is not difficult to see that the
factoring is hard then the standard
proof system
does not simply simulate the system
because if it did
then we would need to we would get the
satisfying assignment
for for formula file
and this is what uh what we believe is
not possible
all right so um
let me quickly go over this uh
natural proof system for sat
you can get natural proof system for sat
if you realize that the
uh phi's inside if the existential
existentially quantified formula has a
quantified tautology
is quantified tautology and then you can
use proof system for quantified
technologies
and you have to go faster
what is interesting that the standard
proof system polynomial simulates the
g-star one
[Music]
details about it and the point is that
um
is the the witnessing theorem of of cook
so the bottom line
is that if you have a witnessing theorem
in a proof system
then it essentially means that
the the standard proof system will
normally simulate it
okay um if there is an optimal proof
system for
saturn that exists complete function np
i wanted to prove this but i don't have
time so
it's a pity because it's a simple proof
so let me finish by saying that uh
we can stay the conjecture the sub
doesn't have an optimal proof system
and what uh the proof that we skipped
gives us that total function and the
conjecture
implies the subconjecture so we can
place
sat into the diagram and it is between
p and column total function and p
conjecture and these things
so we know that many things are
different
in particular these two branches are
really
distinct branches
but unlike showing these implications
which
are usually easy and more or less
straightforward
relativizations are pretty
technical and complicated so we still
don't know whether
these two are different and these two
are different
okay thank you
thank you so much well this is really
really interesting
okay uh we are a little bit over time
but but but
maybe uh
so harvey friedman has this program
showing that this
stronger set theories end up proving
kind of a you need strong set theory to
prove very
mathematically looking statement about
kind of numbers just statement about
numbers here and things like that
and i wonder whether you can use this
program to
show that these stronger sets theory
like axiom
cardinals from cardinal axioms
prove things that actually they have
computational meaning
uh i wish i could but uh i cannot
yeah so
the the problem is that essentially what
we what we are able to
do is just somehow to rephrase
the consistency in some combinatorial
way
but it's not
it's not anything that can be
interpreted as a
statement about computational complexity
but but this is well
i would like to do it and i'm thinking
about it
but i don't know how to do it
thank you i think yes thank you so much
and uh maybe uh while
uh try setting up if anybody has any
more questions for paulo
and thank you so much for watching this
is really interesting
i may ask you a question pavel thank you
for the talk first of all
uh my question is the following consider
the conjecture
that p at that np intersect point p
which is a monthly class has no complete
problem
where would this conjecture fit in your
diagram of connections between the
conjectures
uh this
uh doesn't fit into any of the branches
so it's uh it's in the middle it's
it's stronger than of course uh piano
and p but it's in the middle so we are
i i'm not sure that we can uh
show by relativization that it is not
in any of the branches maybe i can
if he's connected can can tell you more
but it seems that
this is in between thank you
it's possible that there is a third
branch which is
based on this but i don't know other
than than this problem in this direction
so sorry for being
a bit longer than oh
i'm sorry for kind of making it more
loose it needs to be thank you so much
for
this being beautiful so let's if you
don't mind that's
a spoon question till later and
town and the start our grand finale of
two days
uh which is uh the talk by
uh shy ben david
about uh as you could see if p versus p
uh can be independent of the axioms of
reasoning
and uh so just couple of words to
introduce
uh tribe and david his work spans
a really vast range from uh
kind of from such theory of
kind of really uh deep state theory
to really practical machine learning
uh with algorithm and complexity and
logic
and all sorts of things in between
and shy can
connect all those different things and
show the relations
where uh you know it's hard to imagine
that there could even be relations
for example um independent result of a
machine learning problem
uh this is one of your unique's best
paper awards right
no not this was that one not this one
okay so you have other papers
with good new rips best paper awards and
such
anyway so sprite board plants food area
and it's really beautiful and today he's
going to tell us about
that really cool result about sat and
beaver symphony and independence please
okay yeah so i'll try to be and not
technical i know what we're running
behind time so yeah so i i want to look
at this question of whether
p versus np can be independent of set
theory and here
i mean as in contrast to to what sasha
was saying
when you look at negative results the
stronger the
system you can show that cannot prove
something the more
the stronger the result is so i'm
talking i'm really
interested in much stronger systems i'm
not
going to talk about sat or anything how
to solve that
but so what was the talk about so when
you're faced with some hard mathematical
problem there's always the temptation to
think that maybe
this problem is inherently irresolvable
maybe the reason that we fail to find
answers is not
our lack of wisdom but rather than no
answer no proof
exists i mean that's following together
we know that this
is always a possibility when we're
facing an open problem
so the the goal of this research was to
see uh
try to ask why do we fail to resolve
some basic computational complexity
questions
uh could it be that p versus npo other
confidential
open problems are unresolvable
in set theory which means we have no
tools of proving
that the answer and
more concretely is it likely that right
that the
tools that we have in mathematics are
inherently too weak
to determine relationship between
complexity classes
and so i mean if we believe in such a
direction then
we should direct our efforts to
answering these
logical reality questions rather than
struggle with
directly computational complexity issues
because maybe
it's hopeless maybe by showing that i
mean that's you know the
the kind of the line of research that
sasha was taking and
and others in in this community that
don't try this direction because it's
it's a
brutal so um
what do we know about independence move
just to remind
everybody about independence proof of
set theory so
uh gilbert's program was to the hope to
develop a formal method that would
resolve all mathematical questions
and of course gabriel's in completeness
result show that this plan
is bound to fail every reasonable
mathematical framework
has irresolvable question and we will
call
a problem independent of a theort if we
cannot
thicken our proof and either the
statement s no its negation and gathers
show that
the consistency of a theort is always
such an independent statement with
respect to t
but of course what we are interested in
is other
relevant real mathematical questions
that fall in this category of
being unresolvable
by said theory which means unresolvable
by what we
call mathematical proof okay so what do
we know about that
uh so what what is the the
set theory that we look at so
a formal theory that defines kind of
commonly defined what mathematical proof
is about is the set theory
that fc there is a
slightly weaker theory which talks about
arithmetic para arithmetic we all know
it and
just to mention that pan arithmetic is
equivalent
to set theory uh if we just delete
the statement of existing infinite set
so
uh and since says
the lipstick can prove the consistency
of paranoia arithmetic we can
build in zfcm model for a number theory
then we know that it's strictly stronger
than apa
even with respect to statements about
natural numbers because the statement
panel arithmetic is consistent
is can be phrased as a statement above
natural numbers so here is a statement
about natural numbers that
you can prove that we said it with the c
with the assumption with the
extra axiom there exists an infinite set
and you cannot prove this statement
in panoramic although it is a planetary
statement about natural numbers okay so
that's kind of the background
and the paul cohen showed that there are
really questions that are
independent of that theory and the
continuum authorities
and is a kind of a sounding
example of this and since then there
have been many many independence
results in set theory it started with
cardinal
arithmetic and internet combinatorics
group theory
topology function analysis algebra
and recently we had as antonina
mentioned
we had an independent results of set
theory
in for very very basic question machine
learning
so con what can we say about
independence results for computational
complexity do all of this
kind of machinery of being able to show
the things that we depend on
a strong theory does it apply
to a complexity combination complexity
statements
so the uh there is an
old result of uh hopefuls and administ
that says that for any tre team we can
find a turing machine
such as as an the oracle complexity
with respect to this turing machine
cannot be
decided uh in in t this is kind of a
diagonalization
trick and talks about the
oracle ap versus np with respect to some
specially crafted orc so
that was kind of the first result and
then there were
several results of independence of
weaker fragments of uh
arithmetic we also were already
mentioned here some
uh there's some first there were
artificial fragments that were kind of
meant to be weak enough
so that you will not be able to prove
much with those weak fragments
then uh there was a bounded arithmetic
it depends uh like they're famous in
tremendous results of
sasha and all kind of uh
limiting the proof techniques so it
relativized the proofs that was the
the oracle result of uh beggar gill and
solovey and then
uh showed that if you limit the proofs
in a
another way it's exactly what sasha was
talking about
then there are statements you will not
be able to prove and
then later there's the algebraic proofs
of uh
uh but uh
can we prove the independence of p
versus np
from set theory could this be the case
so there are inherent limitations that
the point is that to realize that since
paul coin in 1960
falcon introduced the technique of
forcing
and in some sense we do not have
any new techniques for showing
dependence of set theory
in in a high level they all follow the
same
pattern i will not get into describing
this pattern but
important to notice about it that all
the
proof techniques that we have for
showing independence from set theory
they cannot show independence of any
statements
that involves only natural numbers only
finite sets
so we do not have any technique that has
a hope of showing
independence of statement like p versus
np
because those are finitary statements
existed during machines such that
and there exists a k such it's for all
formulas and so on
everything is planetary all the tools
that we have for showing independence
from
full set theory uh can be
shown and not to be able to show such
independence
so we have to go to uh
that's what i'm trying to explain why
it's a planetary statement it's for
every code p there is a chewing machine
and a k and and so on we know we know
that
p versus n p can be written as a fairly
statement
in in in the language of say a number
theory
so what can we hope to prove so i'm
saying we cannot
we don't have any tools that would be
able to show independence of
p versus and p of uh full set theory
but what about non-probability from
parent arithmetic that's kind of the
next
best thing that we could hope for
so um this is
a weaker theory and a weaker theory it
would be easier to show
a statement that it fails to prove
naturally
and it will be a very interesting result
because independence with respect to a
panel arithmetic
would be quite satisfactory it will tell
you that
without assuming without using
a statement there exist infinite sets we
will not be able to resolve
our complexity uh questions so
showing independence of pan arithmetic i
think would be a
kind of could could be something to hope
for as a mathematician
because it really tells you that we
cannot resolve
a p versus np i mean the the
possibility that for having to resolve
it we have to assume
the existence of infinite sets or even
stronger
infinite carbonyls does not uh
we have no way of incorporating or even
imagining how it could be relevant so
this could be
an interesting goal so i can go back to
my first slide what i'm saying is
rather than trying to solve p versus np
maybe what we should do is try to show
that it is independent of paranormal
arithmetic
if it's independent and para-arithmetic
in some sense
our efforts to show it uh to prove it
are bound
to fail okay so
do we know of any independence from pan
arithmetic or free mathematical
statements so as i mentioned before
we do have results about independence
from
zfc and of course they are independent
from piano arithmetic
but these are all about statements which
involve
infinite sets so do we have any uh
statements about in the independence
from eternal arithmetic
of real mathematical statements of
course the consistency of planner
arithmetic is independent of parent
arithmetic but we want to talk about
inherently mathematical statements so
the first such result was paris and
harrington and that was a
a very a big breakthrough at the time
they took
uh they took a a natural version of
ramsey theorem that we can prove instead
of c that this is a
true theorem it's just the usual website
theorem but just
it's i mean i've not repeated but just
mentioned to those that are familiar
with ramdi
that the only addition here is that the
homogeneous
set that the existence of this set uh
is guaranteed by ramsey theorem should
be larger
than the first natural number in this
city
which seems like a small minor addition
to run this theorem
and it really indeed provable that it's
true but
they showed you cannot prove it internal
arithmetic
so that was kind of giving hope that
there are
mathematical statements about
finite sets that are independent of
parent arithmetic
although the approval in zfc the
question we are aiming for
is to ask is it likely to be the case
for p versus and p
or other complete complexity problems
so uh there are similar results later
statements about natural numbers it's
fun to redistinct the hercules
and the hijra i don't know if you heard
about
this it's kind of a puzzle that you have
a tree
and you have leaves from the tree which
are heads of the hijra
and you are hercules and you have a saw
then you are cutting heads
but each time you're cutting heads it
grows more heads and
it grows on more hands in the scary way
the formula
and still one can prove that no matter
how
bad as the hercules as how cool is you
are
you will eventually kill the hydra but
this eventually is
very long and to prove such a system so
to prove such a statement
uh we can do it in zfc but we cannot do
it in paranormal
and again it's definitely statement
you're playing a game against a
finite tree which is the hitler the
interesting relevance to us
is that the structure of a p not equal
in p
is syntactically it looks the same
as the paris harrington because the
parasance is
a the theorem it says for every
uh ret and the size and the
number of colors there exists a
homogeneous set
of such size and here the
p not equal in p have a very natural
a very similar uh syntactic structure it
says for every x
there exists a y such that phi x y
which is like the ramsey for every
parameters you have
and and size you have a homogeneous set
and the statement
this set is homogeneous end of this site
does not contain
any unbounded quantifiers and it's the
same with p versus nph and you want to
show
that for every program and every
uh bound or the polynomial of the
runtime of the program
there exists a
instance of sat such that this program
will give you the wrong answer
so the statement is syntactically looks
like the paris serengton
so we we could hope that maybe we could
show a similar result
independence of pair and arithmetic for
p
naught equal and p okay so that's
what i'm i was set to try to understand
and the conclusion of this work if we
jump
right to the end is that
a
if on one hand if that can be solved
in almost polynomial time so say p is
not equal in p
but sat can be solved in time which is
very very close to being polynomial and
then elaborate on it later
if that can be solved in almost
polynomial tile
then you cannot prove that p
is not equal in p and now the
concrete notion of almost polynomial
depends on the theory
in which you want to prove it so for
every theory there is a notion of
close to polynomial such that if
np is sat can be solved in such close to
polynomial time
then that theory will not be able to
prove
the separation between p and p because
th the sat has the solution that looks
almost like polynomial
and the theory the the almost will be so
fine
that the theory will not be able to
distinguish between the two
so that's not so not so much of a
surprising result but it's something
that's worthwhile to bear in mind and
i'll
get back to it a bit later but the
surprise here
is that we also can show the other
direction
so if the theory is sufficiently strong
then the reverse statement also holds
namely
the only possible reason for failure of
the theory to prove that p is not equal
in p
is that sat can be solved by an
algorithm which is almost polynomial
time
so in some sense it says
loosely stated that if you can prove
that
a strong mathematical theory cannot show
that p is not equal in p you will imply
that sat has a solution which is almost
polynomial time
so solving the logical statement the
higher level logical statement
p versus independent of set theory
will be as hard as coming up
with a polynomial almost polynomial time
for
that so in some sense that let's say the
main conclusion of this of this talk
that there's no point of in
you don't get much advantage by
struggling with logic and trying to show
that p versus and p is independent of
set theory because
this will be as hard as showing that you
have a polynomial
uh algorithm almost from the argument
okay so that's at this point i i said
the most important things of the talk
and now i want to go a little bit into
the technical details and and kind of
convey the intuition which is not so
complex at all
of why this is indeed the case
so we would consider
what do we mean by almost polynomial i'm
talking now about
sats has a solution which is almost
polynomial time
so what do we mean by almost polynomial
so we look at running time which is n to
the fn
where the exponent f n grows very very
slowly
so it means that the running time has
a constant exponent for huge
stretches of input length
so the function f n i want it to grow
very very slowly the exponential the
exponent of n
of the runtime and if the function goes
very slowly we can view it as the
inverse
of a fast growing function so we will
it will be in some sense it's easier to
talk about how fast
a function grows rather than talking
about
how slow it does so i'll
we'll talk about the inverse of the
function which
is the exponent of the runtime
so what here are some fast-growing
functions the
wayne a hierarchy so this is a way of
constructing very fast-growing functions
so f1 of
n is 2n and now for every
ordinal countable ordinal lambda
f lambda plus one of n is just you apply
f of f of f you compose n time
f lambda and apply to n and
if you take a limit ordinal then
you also have to define it for a limit
ordinary for a limit ordinal
you just at the end step you apply you
take a sequence
delta n that converges to
delta limit ordinal and that ends
for to compute f of n you apply
the function composed
the delta of n times so
this is a very a way of defining a very
fast growing functions the aquaman
function is just
f omega is the first uh
infinite ordinal in this sequence it's
only the optimal function
but then as we see here we can keep
going we can
applying it further and further and
further and get faster and faster
growing
function that's the kind of the
functions that
we will talk about whose inverses will
be
the exponents of the runtime
if indeed you could prove independence
of p versus np
so just to demonstrate here i know i
mean this is a sophisticated audience i
don't have to convince you
but like f f 2
of 3 is already a crazy
number somehow something hides for me
but anyway anybody can do these
calculations
it's crazy first even f3
f omega is aquaman's function and we go
beyond it
okay now how far beyond that we go when
we want our functions to grow very very
very fast
so it's common to denote by epsilon 0
the first
ordinal such that omega to the power
alpha equals alpha with the powers here
are
ordinal powers but and i i will not get
in the definition
but this is the limit of omega omega to
the power omega omega to the power omega
2 omega
and we take the countable uh
limit of this so
this is epsilon zero and
we will be interested in the function f
epsilon zero so we take this when a
hierarchy
and we push it and push it and push it
we go through
the aquaman function is just here at f
omega
and then we keep going and going and
going and going and we get to this
stationary point fixed point of this
function
and we take this crazily growing
function why do we care about this
function
so we care about such a function because
it has i mean
the next step is the way i connect
fast-growing functions and complexity
conjectures i mean this is
fun to talk about fast-forwarding
functions and hidden and so on
but it does relate to computational
complexity
so how do we make the connection
so given a
a complexity class which has
which you can enumerate as a countable
set of algorithms some canonical
enumeration of the class
i guess this is what pablo was calling a
syntactic class and given a language
i can define a function and the function
it measures how well can this
class approximate the language l
so this function at the point i
it is the maximum of so i go over
m1 m2 m3 and so on up to mi
and i see which of them can compute
l correctly on longer initial segments
so again i go over all functions in
here is my class m one and two and so on
i'm going up
at point i i'm going over all the i
first i machines
or first i programs and then
for each of them i look at the minimum
point where it fails to compute my
language l
and i take the maximum so this tells me
how many machines do i have to consider
in order to correctly compute the
language l
on the first uh
i a or um
how how far can any of the first
machines can compute my language this is
what we are doing here
so we define a function that
measures how well can a class of
functions
approximate a given language and
it is easy to realize that this function
is total
if and only if l is not in the class
because if l is in the class there will
be some i
such that there will never be a failure
this
machine mi will compute the class com
correctly
and we are just looking at the first
time that all the first i machines
fail so this is a total function for
every i there is
a number out of i if and only if the
function
is not in the class and furthermore
the faster this function grows the
closer
is l to the class because it means that
fewer machines right f i tells me
how far could any of the first i
machines
compute l correctly so if it grows fast
it means that i need few machines
to compute big stretches l on big
stretches of x's so
the faster this function grows the
closer
is the class the function the language
l to the class c so here we
kind of measure how far it's not just p
not equal in p but i'm trying to measure
how far
is sat from the class of polynomial time
functions so it gives a quantitative
measure and this is the function that
will
apply our knowledge about our
discussion of fast-growing functions so
we enumerate all p-time machines
and we assume that we have
some kind of easy mapping computable
mapping from index i
to the code of the ice machine and we
can without loss of generality assume
that the ice machine
is bounded by n to the log i i mean
they're all
just enumerating for normal time
machines and then we can get this
nice connection between this function
out and
the computational complexity of
computing sat
so if r is this approximation
function of sat by a p
then sat is in deterministic time
d to the log g of n
for every function g that bounds r minus
one so now let's
stop and see what it means r
is how easy i can how far i can
approximate
a sat r is a function that
if sat that grows very fast
so r minus 1 is a very slow growing
function
and i so g is just a computable function
that
up about r minus 1 and it means that if
sat can be approximated well
by this procedure by enumerating all
polynomial machines
then sat is in deterministic time
which this is a very close to constant
very slow growing function
because almond r is fast growing r minus
one is very slow growing i take the log
of it
and so i have this in the exponent the
exponent is almost a constant
so we're using fast growing functions
we're looking at the inverses
as a way of measuring how close that is
to p
and the quality is that the
approximation
rate of p by
sat gives us a notion of almost
polynomial time algorithm
so if the approximation rate is fast
is a fast growing function then sat is
really almost polynomial
the exponent is almost a constant
okay so at this point we have the
ingredients for our reasoning
we have the notion of fast-growing
function and the relation to sat
and the class but p course what we want
to do is relate it
to a probability so what's the
connection between this
and and and probability
uh or in particular out of the
probability of p versus
np so a function is called
probably recursive i guess you all know
it if you can prove
in your theory that uh it holds
they have an algorithm that computes
this function and holds on every input
and the
probably recursive functions respect to
pa
and pa1 i haven't yet defined p1 and
defined in a second it's the
pi 1 closure of pa it's the same so
we can talk about being proven recursive
without making this distinction and
there is the way in our theorem and the
way that when i was this is from this
hierarchy
and the function is every f alpha for
alpha less than epsilon zero is probably
recursive
and this is if in some sense it's if and
only if
if a function is supposedly recursive
then it is dominated by some
f alpha so this minor hierarchy what it
gives
us is a way to
determine how fast can a function grow
and still be provably recursive
still we could prove that for every x
there is
f of x and the answer is that roughly
the bound is this f epsilon 0
in the wine hierarchy so
the corollary is that if a function
grows very fast
it's not dominated by any of those
functions
then piano arithmetic and it's closure
by pi one functions by parallel
statements
cannot prove that the function is total
i guess i don't have time to explain the
the result it's a classical result it's
a beautiful result but
if a function goes too fast you cannot
prove that this function is total
and the parasiton actually the proof
that a piranha arithmetic cannot resolve
this
ramsey type trm is that is exactly by
showing that the
ramsey number that you take parameters
and you want to
ask how fast should your graph be in
order to get such homogeneous set
it's such a fast-growing function that
it's beyond the scope
of what panel arithmetic can prove it is
complete and in parallel it
cannot prove that it's complete it
cannot prove that
for every input parameters there is
indeed
a large enough graph that will give you
a homogeneous set for these parameters
so this is exactly the the tool the
machinery behind the paris ericton
independence result
and
most of the proofs of independent from
prior arithmetics of
statements that we can prove in zfc
instead theory
have this kind of nature they generate a
very fast growing function and show that
this
fast point function is beyond the limit
that is stated by weiner's theorem
so this repeats in other independence
proof
respect to plan arithmetic
so what we can conclude here that if the
approximation rate
of sat by p is very fast going function
then parallel arithmetic cannot prove
that p
is not equal in p and
so if sat can be solved by an almost
polynomial time algorithm
then para arithmetic will not be able to
prove
that they are different okay so that's
one direction of our theorem
the maybe the more interesting direction
is the other direction
um so
uh the inverses of fast-growing
functions are functions that are
very very almost constant they're on big
stretches
they're constant i'm trying to rush
because i see the clock
we're getting too close to a two o'clock
here
and the end of the recording
so what i'm saying is that if a function
goes very fast
uh if the this function out
the approximation grows very fast then
there are long stretches on which sat
can be solved in
a fixed polynomial so the next step is
showing that this is the only reason
for non-probability of p versus np
and i show it with respect to the theory
pa1 pa1
is a i add to p and arithmetic all the
pi 1
true statements now pa1
so expand arithmetic plus all the taiwan
formulas that are
true in standard models of arithmetic
and what do we know about this property
of a1 it's not a recursive theory
that's a big negative but
there is some notion some notion of some
sense of representative representation
independence
uh i mean it has that it's exactly the
theory that we need
in order to be able to show that
if you have two turing machine to prove
that two turing machines can compute
the same function are indeed
uh computing the same function so in
order to show
representation independence of turing
machines we need
the theory pa1 and
so it's in some sense it's a natural
theory to consider when we want to talk
about
uh independence of runtime and turing
machines
and we can also
nice properties if p equals and p then p
and y and can prove it because you can
have this polynomial time algorithm
and pa1 can prove the statement for
every
input it computes sat correctly
okay so we switch to the theory pa1
which is much
stronger and now we have the theorem
that
uh p a 1 proves p
equals not equal in p if and only if
the approximation rate of p is
low or in other way in other
words so i mean before i
talk about the proof idea what we we
care about here
is to show that player 1 will be able to
if if sat is far from p pa1 will be able
to show it
and the only reason that it cannot show
it could be that sat
is very very close to p and the
the proof idea i guess we don't have
much time for proofs now
but we can write this as a pi one
statement so
the conclusion is that if pa1 fails to
prove
a p naught equal and p then sat has
almost polynomial time algorithms
and more on the significance
so i want to show that if pa1
cannot prove that they are different i
mean
then in some in some sense we cannot
distinguish
independence proof between pa1 and pa
because the generic way in which we show
that the theory does not prove some
statement
the the forcing style
is to start with the model we assume
that the theory is consistent so we have
a model m
we construct the sub model in which
you get the opposite of the of the
statement
and such a sub model will also
satisfy the pi 1 theory of the first
model
so what i'm saying any tool that we have
with the hope of showing that something
is independent of piano arithmetic
will also show us independence of pa1
and therefore if we could show
independence of sat
of p versus and p it will mean that sati
is very close to p
so this is the bottom line so
if it is provable that p versus p is
independent of
p a then sat can be solved in
deterministic
time t to the g of n where
g is a very very slow growing function
of g minus one
is a very fast growing function which
will mean
that sat is almost in p and that's if
and only if statement
i think i've just we have similar
results for silicon complexity
we can show that for example if
a piano arithmetic cannot show
if p versus and p is independent of
planar arithmetic
then there are no one-way functions and
all kind of results
in this nature but i am out of time
so i will stop here and take some
questions if we can still take
questions thank you so much
yeah let's please ask questions
and uh sorry for riding over time but
please do ask questions
if if somebody asks may i ask the really
naive question
i have a question oh yeah uh you you
have a question okay
go ahead okay does um this
the proof technique also allow you to go
uh
further down in the strength of the
theory for instance
to replace piano arithmetic by i sigma 1
and
m f epsilon naught by akaman
that's an interesting that it it seems
that i mean
it's an interesting direction i haven't
thought about it i haven't thought about
wicked theories
i mean as sasha was saying right at the
start i come from
working on zfc but yeah i think it's a
very interesting uh
question it's not inconceivable
[Music]
okay
more questions
for you please please yeah yeah
so so i understand the the the message
uh is that um the problem is that we are
not able to distinguish between pa
and pa1 we are not not really able to
uh understand what uh what are the basic
things in uh arithmetic we we know what
what is the induction but uh if ghana
ethnic
was formalized with some stronger
basic theory then everything that we are
able to prove about
arithmetic would be the same
and this is what what i also i
completely agree with you
but i i would like to add that the
similar thing is
in complexities here that we are not
able to
distinguish computations that
have different basic operations
like say if we allow
turing machine and access to oracle and
say well what the oracle computes
is the elementary operation so
then uh various things can happen and
this is the
relativizations so so that i think it's
an interesting election
sorry i think it's a very interesting
analogy right
yes okay
actually a question to both of you
because i kept thinking about the
relation between
your talk shy and [ __ ] stock i will
talk about
uh somalia classes and the question of
complete problems and you heavily use
the fact
that p is a syntactic class right is
that right
so is there any kind of connection
between those
yeah i really don't i mean i use very
heavily i mean all of this
line of uh all of this machinery is uh
about syntactic classes right
and thomas is asking you to show the
second last slide again
okay this one or the before that
uh you can download before that
yes thanks right
yeah this is about why why we cannot
distinguish pa1 from pierre but pavel
was talking about yeah
so do you want me to repeat it or you
want to ask something about it
no thank you oh okay
sorry i have i have very naive question
so
assume that i am telling you that
npe is not a subset of quasi-polynomial
time in the real world
right
it means or or maybe i mean something or
you are saying that it implies
that p is not equal to np slightly
weaker statement
is probable in piano artist
is what you're saying yeah
yeah is a rough way of putting it right
sounds sounds very strong to me
no it's not provable in piano arithmetic
it's proven in pa one
and that won't be
one slide further or where you have a
result
here which is it says period
yeah yeah but but here it is the the
here
i have the caveat by any method known
today so what public
bubble was saying correctly i mean
probably we can show it will be
uh provable in pa1
but there is no mathematical tool that
will distinguish pa1 from pa
so now we have to take a second step on
top of it and saying
by existing tools okay good
okay thank you
more question comments to any speakers
to and from any speakers
okay thank you very very much everybody
this is
such a fantastic session sorry for
running our time but i don't
want it to end this is fantastic
so um if people are interested we could
go
to um if you are an attendee i posted a
link
to gather town in the chat this is a
workshop blatter town
and if you want to put
anybody who wants is welcome to come
there and
pick a chat and uh yes so thank you so
much
uh safer paddle and try all three of
your talks
are so inspiring and really make you
think about
you know about the basic questions so
thank you very very much
thank you